former bachelor Ben Higgins and his
fiancee Lauren Bushnell opened up about
the struggles of living their life in
the limelight
this isn't gonna break us et caught up
with the couple at the iHeartRadio Music
Festival in Las Vegas on Friday where
they candidly revealed how they're
dealing with body shaming on social
media you start to question yourself but
I think for me I've just really tried to
accept Who I am and kind of honestly
accept like you can't change that I'm
not gonna spend the free time that I
have trying to change the person I was
made to be it doesn't make it easy but I
think for me I've tried to accept the
role that I've been given and try to
tell like young women that it's okay to
be who you are and like no matter how
you're built or no matter who you are
like be who you are because that's the
most beautiful that you will ever be
it's tough
Lauren handles it very well but it's not
always easy the pair also offered some
words of wisdom for the new bachelor
Nick vile my advice to NIC was you could
come out of this with a very serious
relationship but before you do make sure
it's somebody you want to commit to make
sure it's somebody that you want to
pursue that you want to work through all
this with because if not it can get hard
Ben and Lauren are definitely committed
to one another over the weekend they
celebrated their one-year anniversary of
meeting each other on the ABC reality
show Lauren took to Instagram to gush
over the milestone posting this adorable
pic and sweetly writing in the caption
quote one year ago today my life
completely changed so incredibly blessed
to have met this amazing human
person